more drama what we are learning now  about gwen stefani split yeah how about  this last week sources close to gavin  rossdale told us that gwen caught a  break in her divorce settlement with  gavin but we have learned from a  separate source that the singer may be  less than happy with the situation and  especially with the fact that she now  has to sell her home which also means  she will have to uproot her children  yeah and go and actually bought that  house that was once owned by Jennifer  Lopez in 2006 she made significant  upgrades adding a guest house and an  entire new wing as you moved in when her  oldest son Kingston was just three  months old so basically it is the only  house that those children have ever  known which is a good point meanwhile  last night there was no bitterness when  Gwen hit the stage at the voice for a  performance there she was all boho  tribal with her braids and feathers  debuting her song misery while Blake  watched with pride